your spine is composed of individual
Bones called vertebrae
your vertebrae form a protective tunnel
called the spinal canal which surrounds
the spinal cord as it travels down the
length of your spine on each side of the
spinal cord spinal nerves exit the
spinal canal
through small bony channels called
neural foramina
your lumbar spine is the lower third of
your spinal column between each vertebra
a flexible pad called an intervertebral
disc acts as a shock absorber for your
spine lumbar disc pressure can increase
by more than 50 percent when you change
from a standing position to bending over
or by more than 80% between a standing
position and sitting with no back
support
the intervertebral discs tough outer
ring is known as the annulus fibrosus
the soft gel-like center is called the
nucleus pulposus
during a traumatic injury your spine may
lurch forward forcefully causing your
vertebra to compress the front of one or
more of your lumbar discs beyond normal
limits
as a result the back of your disc
protrudes backward
causing small tears and thinning of your
annulus fibrosus
over time your damaged annulus fibrosus
may weaken and change shape and your
nucleus pulposus may dry out and lose
flexibility as your intervertebral disk
deteriorates your nucleus pulposus may
push your annulus outward resulting in a
disc bulge
depending on its location the Bulge may
push on or impinge one of your spinal
nerves your spinal cord or your cauda
equina which is a collection of spinal
nerve roots at the end of your spinal
cord central disc bulges protrude
backward into your spinal canal
lateral disc bulges extend into your
neural foramen severe lumbar disc
injuries can tear your annulus fibrosus
pressure from your vertebra may push
your nucleus pulposus out of your torn
annulus causing a disc herniation a
herniated lumbar disc can impinge upon
your cauda equina or spinal nerves and
cause symptoms such as pain numbness or
weakness in one or both of your legs
treatments for lumbar disc injuries may
include rest anti-inflammatory
medication muscle relaxants
ice or heat applied to the injured area
physical therapy an epidural steroid
injection given directly into the area
of nerve irritation
and in more severe cases surgery